foreign
looks like a latrina has a question for
us how do we break free from
procrastination and behaviors that don't
move us towards our goals Lewis how do
we not let our amateur procrastination
turn pro
man I think it's I think it's really
getting clear I think the enemy of
greatness is lacking a meaningful
mission
um and there's a difference between
success and greatness and I think you
guys can resonate with this my whole
life I wanted to be successful that's
what I was driven to do and to be but it
was based off of a wound
so I was driven to succeed Ryan to
to look good to be respected to get the
audience to make more money so that
people would appreciate me essentially
right though because it was from a wound
where people I didn't feel appreciated
you know
and I didn't feel seen
and I accomplished all these successes
and it still didn't feel good it still
didn't feel like I was enough
in success I've learned
it's not bad or wrong it's by itself
selfish success is for me to accomplish
something it's for me to win it's for me
to make a certain amount of money
greatness what I've learned over the
last 10 years since I was realizing
success by itself doesn't work greatness
is about how can I
accomplish my mission but be in service
to others along the way and as Kobe said
when I interviewed him it's making an
impact on the people around you where
they then impacted people around them
and it continues that's greatness it's
not about winning it's not about
succeeding it's not about making the
money getting the downloads whatever it
is
about doing those things in service of
others that's greatness so I think it's
reevaluating your goals and saying is
this a part of a bigger meaningful
mission in my life
and a meaningful mission is defined by
impacting the people around you it's not
just about what you want
so yes it includes what you want but it
must be in the service of
generosity and impact in others around
you as well yeah that's it I love that
health is not primarily defined by the
abstinence from unhealthy activities
it's it's defined by your immersion into
activities that are life-giving and and
abstaining from unhealthy things bad
habits and so on that's kind of like a
organic response to you having a healthy
point of Focus right so if you're
looking at actions you're taking that
are unhealthy things you want to quit
doing things you want to let go of ask
yourself well why
is it because someone else made me feel
guilty about it is because someone else
says that I'm a bad person for doing
these things do I want to let go of
these things for myself and if I do that
means I'm presupposing the beauty of
some other life I would rather be living
if my time wasn't being occupied with
this what does that life look like
because you got to have a vision that's
compelling enough to make you say yeah
this is holding me back from something
that's so much better guilt won't do it
there are possibilities born out of love
and passion that simply don't arise out
of a sense of guilt and externally
imposed Duty what is that mission yes
what is that Vision that compels you
yeah listen you know
well I mean it's going to be challenging
either way but if we don't love
something enough if we're not excited
about it the challenges are going to
make us feel burnt out and overwhelmed
you guys have a lot going on you gotta
you got a big business a big Community
you've got expenses you've got costs
you've got all these things happening if
you didn't truly have a vision or a
mission more meaningful than just let's
be successful and make money the
challenges and adversities that come not
every day but when they come in Seasons
to be like exhausting and draining but
because you do what you do for your
community you do it for a bigger Mission
then just self yes it's for self and
others because of that it allows you to
get up with more excitement every day
more con more consistently even when
you've got stresses and challenges in
life whatever might happen so that's
what I think it's just shifting your
goals into a meaningful Mission you know
one other thing I say building on this
about the pro the procrastination piece
is that um procrastination isn't
necessarily a sign that you're being
lazy it might be a sign that you're
being lazily ambitious and what I mean
by that is lazily ambitious is when you
set a goal that's like really big and
and it sounds flattering but it's so
vague you don't have to do anything
right my goal is to really be healthy no
you got to be clear my goal is to be
free you know that's that's lazely
ambitious because it's a positive goal
but it's not defined enough to hold me
accountable to anything right and when
you're setting goals it's important that
you set your goals for what you know you
can achieve on the worst day of the week
what I see holding a lot of people back
when it comes to procrastination is they
set these huge goals like I've never
worked out a day in my life I'm
completely out of shape but starting
tomorrow I'm gonna train for a marathon
I'm gonna run five miles a day well
what's gonna happen you're going to
procrastinate when tomorrow comes it's
going to feel really overwhelming
however if you scale that back and say
all right I know that every week I'm
gonna have a terrible day where
everyone's need and all kinds of things
are going wrong what can I do on that
day well I can get up I can put on my
clothes and I can go run for two blocks
all right that's my commitment I'm doing
that every day now when I have that bad
day I'm gonna tell myself I can at least
run two blocks and I go out there and do
it but what happens when I actually get
out there it's actually easier to
procrastinate the process of going back
home changing my clothes getting in the
shower that's easy to procrastinate it
easier to keep going forward and say I'm
going to keep running and just do a
couple of Miles while I'm out here right
so when you set smaller goals you give
yourself the opportunity to build
momentum but sometimes we fear doing
that because we don't want to insult the
craft I don't want to insult the craft I
don't want to insult physical fitness
Fitness by setting this small laughable
goal but that small laughable goal is
what allows you to become a powerful
person over time through momentum so
start small yeah well I also think a lot
of people just lack Clarity like you
said they're not defining what they want
specifically and I in a meaningful
mission is what is it in one sense that
you're trying to do with this season of
life again that can be
I want to run a marathon in two years
but this season of life this is my
meaningful Mission it's to do whatever
uh you know a half a mile a day for
three days a week for this period of
time so I did I talk about getting super
clear on what your meaningful Omission
is I don't care if you're from the first
caller who is trying to leave the job
that you don't like what is the
meaningful Mission and get clarity
and this is a good practice for everyone
watching live or at home or listening
later in one sentence what is it for
this season of life for you for me I'm
very clear in one sentence my meaningful
mission is to serve and impact 100
million lives every single week to help
them improve the quality of their life
that's it it's very clear that is my
meaningful Mission and it makes it easy
to say yes and no to things that either
serve or don't serve that mission
so I don't feel like I'm procrastinating
because I know where I'm heading it
excites me it gives me energy
and I know that I need to keep growing
and developing and empowering others
around me in order to get closer to that
meaningful Mission did you enjoy this
Standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free